well tomorrow is st patrick's day and we
are heading to
new york new york to get a sneak peek at
all of the safe and fun they have
planned yeah the new york new york hotel
that is where
rocky is right now live with more hey
rocky
hey you guys okay in honor of st
patrick's day tomorrow
it's time to drink up all right you
ready harley sorry this is our intern
all right let's go take it back
okay just kidding it was pepsi thanks
girl all right so let's talk to jason
over here we are at the bar at times
square at the new york new york hotel
how can we celebrate with you guys
tomorrow you got a lot planned we do we
are super excited this year to be
celebrating st
patrick's day yeah we're going to kick
off the celebration here in times square
bar at noon
with our learning early yeah starting
early that's how we do it here in new
york
but no we'll kick off the bar at noon
the piano player sarah and her friends
will be kicking off at 1 pm
we'll go to 2am highly encouraging
guests to make reservations as it's
going to be
a packed house tomorrow we are going to
be focused on health and safety as
always
protecting our guests and our employees
so make reservations early as occupancy
is limited
all right i've seen a few people walk up
to the to the bar already asking how
they can set their reservations so i
imagine this place is going to be pretty
packed
you know safely of course very safely
all right thank you so much jason i'm
going to move over here to sarah
to learn a little bit about you know the
st patrick's day
essentials what does one need to bring
on st patrick's day to the bar at times
square their fire
and their willingness to have a good
time yes
i like that so obviously you're one of
the piano players here
what goes on i hear the piano duel yeah
usually uh when we're up to par
it is two of us going back and forth
taking requests
just uh fostering a really good
environment of just
sing along clap along which we are going
to do tomorrow
just in a very safe way that makes a lot
of sense i'm so excited to learn a
little tune you said sing along so
naturally
i can't do this without this is a very
popular irish pub song
it's called whiskey in a jar okay and
all you have to do
is
[Music]
hey okay i'm gonna keep working on that
okay
i'm gonna keep working on that um it's
mooshow rink did it inc
all right that's your lesson for
tomorrow so bring your moonshot
ringtones
to var at times square here at new york
new york i'll send it back to you
thank you rocky i actually know the
metallica version of that so i'll go
there and sing with you we'll check back
in with you during the 4pm newscast